[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans un monde presque à court de
carburant les meilleurs ingénieurs
tentent de trouver des solutions de
remplacement solaire géothermie éolien
et fusion thermonucléaire
et
chaque seconde l'énergie produite au
coeur du soleil pour alimenter notre
civilisation pendant un million d'années
[Musique]
reproduire l'énergie du soleil une
source d'énergie sans limites sans
risque ni déchets a dit l'ong
[Musique]
si vous réussissez à reproduire la
fusion je crois qu'on a tous tiré les
souffrances de beaucoup de gens et qu'on
permettrait à beaucoup d'être à l'abri
du besoin
l'environnement serait plus propre la
fusion c'est notre grave
[Musique]
d'ici 40 ans la population humaine
atteindra 9 milliards d'individus
une fourmilière instable ou exploseront
les besoins en énergie des pays
émergents il faut faire autrement on
sait la consommation des pays
occidentaux est bien plus élevé que dans
les pays en développement
jusqu'à plusieurs centaines de fois dans
certains cas
et la raréfaction prévu de l'eau douce
va rendre la désalinisation obligatoire
à grande échelle ce qui demandera encore
plus d'énergie
cela n'empêchera pas les besoins en
énergie des pays développés de continuer
à croître
l'humanité dépend encore à 80 %
d'énergies fossiles en voie d'épuisement
après s'être construite sur ces énergies
fossiles notre société doit léguer à sa
descendance des solutions de
remplacement
à elles seules les énergies
renouvelables vont avoir du mal à
alimenter les industries et les
mégapoles du futur aujourd'hui pour
remplacer une centrale électrique il
faut 150 kilomètres carrés de panneaux
solaires ou 2500 éolienne de 50 mètres
de diamètre et du vent
sans de nouvelles sources d'énergie
puissante et durable nous préparons à
subir une catastrophe environnementale
et économique
on est vraiment convaincu que la fusion
nucléaire est l'une des réponses aux
problèmes énergétiques sans danger le
combustible est disponible de façon nous
pensons donc que la fusion doit être
l'une des responsables
[Musique]
dans leurs laboratoires les
scientifiques tentent de recréer le
soleil en miniature certes mais plus
efficace est dix fois plus chaud que
l'original ce défi est là s'avère aussi
dix fois plus compliqué a relevé que le
scientifique ne l'avait prévu il y à 60
ans je ne sais pas pourquoi mais c'est
une passion qui m'a submergé son doute
l'idée de recréer une étoile en
laboratoire qui m'excite j'y passe
toutes mes journées est la nuit j'ai
souvent des idées nouvelles qui nous
viennent des fusions et le moteur de
l'univers c'est comme ça que les épaules
fonctionne
pour comprendre ce qu'est la fusion il
nous faut revenir en arrière
à la naissance des étoiles
la force de gravitation capture les
atomes d'hydrogène issus du big bang
elle les rassemblant dimanche nuages qui
s'effondre sur eux mêmes
sous l'effet de la pression la
température s'élève de plusieurs
millions de degrés la fusion
thermonucléaire peut alors s'amorcer les
noyaux des atomes d'hydrogène se
regroupent pour engendrer de l'hélium en
dégageant encore plus de chaleur
au coeur du soleil depuis quatre
milliards et demi d'années la fusion
brûle inlassablement des noyaux
d'hydrogène
chaque seconde 600 millions de tonnes
d'hydrogène sont convertis en hélium
mais 4 millions de tonnes ont disparu
transformer en énergie en chaleur et en
lumières indispensable à notre existence
pour recréer leur propre soleil en
laboratoire et scientifiques doivent
amener la matière aux confins des états
physiques connus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il existe plusieurs voies pour parvenir
à la fusion de nombreuses équipes sont à
l'oeuvre
cependant trois techniques qui tiennent
le peloton de tête
premiers concurrents
la z machine qui provoquera la réaction
de fusion à l'aide de décharges
électriques
cette installation a été créée pour
travailler sur les armes nucléaires mais
maintenant nous faisons aussi beaucoup
d'expérience pour parvenir à la fusion
contrôlée
on va créer une étoile miniature d'un
autre laboratoire
deuxième équipe le laser mégajoule dont
les rayons vont couperez ces débits
d'hydrogène jusqu'à faire fusionner
leurs atomes le carburant de l'énergie
de fusion sera tirée de la glère et ce
carburant est quasi inépuisable
[Musique]
enfin iter qui en fermera une réaction
de fusion continue dans une cage
magnétique en forme d'anneau appelé
tokamak les quantités d'énergie mise en
jeu sont des millions de fois plus
puissante que pour une réaction chimique
conventionnel
le gagnant sera la première équipe
capable de développer une technologie
produisant plus d'énergie qu'elle n'en
consomme pour enclencher la réaction de
fusion
[Musique]
à cadarache en provence une colonne
entière et niveler pour accueillir iter
1 km de long par 400 mètres de large
2,3 millions de mètres cubes ont été
déplacées presque le volume de la
pyramide de khéops les matériaux
récupérés sont triés et réutilisés sur
place pour aplanir le terrain
[Musique]
les pierres concassées entreront dans la
composition du béton ou fourniront les
fondations des votes circulation
[Applaudissements]
versailles voilà on est sur le site
guiter c'est là que le réacteur à fusion
rail construit
les 16 milliards d'euros du budget it
erp de la construction jusqu'au
démantèlement sont difficilement à la
portée d'un seul pays
les gouvernements de nations
représentant plus de la moitié de la
population mondiale collaborent
l'union européenne les états unis la
russie la chine l'inde le japon et la
corée du sud
chacun des partenaires doit fournir un
certain nombre de pièces pour la
construction de la machine
iter restera un réacteur expérimental
unique construit pour prouver la
faisabilité de la fusion contrôlée
c'est une machine de laboratoire qui
n'est pas prévu pour produire de
l'électricité on n'en est pas là son
objectif est de maintenir une réaction
de fusion continue restituant dix fois
la puissance de départ et cela durant
plusieurs minutes
cette durée permettent aux scientifiques
de prouver que la technologie fonctionne
[Musique]
énergie nucléaire veut dire énergie des
noyaux les centrales nucléaires tels que
nous les connaissons utilisent des
réacteurs à fission la fission consiste
à casser les noyaux de gros atomes
d'uranium l'énergie libérée sous forme
de chaleur fait tourner des turbines
produisant de l'électricité
mais la fission comporte des dangers
personne n'a oublié tient mobile et l'on
n'a toujours pas de solution
satisfaisante pour les déchets à vie
longue sur par nature kazim est propre
la fusion agite al'inverse de la fission
elle regroupe les noyaux au lieu de les
casser
la réaction de fusion met en jeu deux
noyaux légers qui fusionnent pour en
créer un plus lourd
ce processus dégage énormément d'énergie
comme le décrit l'équation d'einstein e
mc2
à 150 millions de degrés la matière
devient du plasma dix fois plus chaud
qu'au coeur du soleil
[Musique]
cette chaleur permet au noyau de vaincre
la répulsion magnétique qui les éloigne
les atomes fusionnent en libérant
énormément d'énergie
les éléments les plus faciles à combiner
sont deux formes d'hydrogène
le deutérium et le tritium le deutérium
se trouve en quantité illimitée dans
l'océan
quant au tritium ont l'extrait d'un
métal très répandue dans la croûte
terrestre ou dans l'eau de mer
le lithium si l'on faisait fusionner les
atome de deutérium et de tritium contenu
dans un litre d'eau de mer on
obtiendrait la même énergie qu avec 360
litres d'essence
on a du carburant pour des millions
d'années pour vous donner un élément de
comparaison avec le deutérium contenu
dans une baignoire d'eau et le lithium
d'une batterie d'ordinateurs portables
il y assez d'énergie pour subvenir aux
besoins de l'individu moyen pour 30 ans
un seul gramme du mélange équivaut à 9
tonnes de pétrole une énergie suffisante
pour permettre un véhicule de faire
trois fois le tour de la terre c'est un
processus où on a un placement confiné
dans un champ magnétique et si les
conditions ne sont pas idéales
la réaction s'arrête immédiatement il
est donc impossible d'avoir une réaction
qui s'en va
la réaction à proprement parler ne
produit pas de déchets dangereux mais
sous l'effet du bombardement de neutrons
la paroisse finira par être légèrement
radioactives
après vingt à trente ans de service iter
sera démonté en l'espace d'une centaine
d'années la radioactivité des composants
retombera et la plupart des déchets
pourront être déclassé
peter à tous ces avantages propres sur
carburants illimité g300 collègues dans
les bureaux 1 km derrière vous qui
pensent la même chose et c'est pour ça
qu'on est là pour construire sur la cave
mais l'histoire ne commence pas là tout
près du chantier se trouve corps supra
un tokamak qui préfigure ce que sera
iter
le mot tout cas mac et le raccourci de
l'expression russe qui signifie chambre
toroïdale de confinement magnétique donc
là ça ça me permet quand même de monter
à des températures de
100 millions de degrés c'est ce qui
permet d'atteindre des conditions
requises pour la fusion
[Musique]
les physiciens et ingénieurs de tore
supra imagine et est en permanence de
nouveaux dispositifs les meilleures
options seront ensuite transposé sur
iter mais à plus grande échelle et
préfigureront les réacteurs à fusion du
futur
en ce moment les scientifiques de tore
supra change certaines antennes de
chauffage du plasma par micro ondes
philippe moreau le pilote de la machine
vient assister à la manoeuvre on savoir
dans iter le design n'est pas
complètement figé donc là on est en
train d'installer une antenne de
chauffage et brident doit permettre dans
iter d'offrir de nouvelles options pour
chauffer le placera et pour allonger la
durée des décharges serge pauli a
participé à la construction de la
machine il la connaît donc parfaitement
mais pour diriger cette manoeuvre il l'a
répété le mouvement toute la matinée
avec son équipe pas décidé et est donc
ça va vous êtes mort mais buté contre la
glissière là on est d'accord ça leur
fera un tokamak la place est utilisé
complètement donc s'il y avait eu un
espace vide on aurait installé quelque
chose un système de mesure pour quoi que
ce soit donc tout est utilisé à 100 % je
t'envoie les protections
que de toute façon il ya très peu de
place pour installer les systèmes par
ailleurs au millimètre pour l'aider avec
la molette
au casino
six mètres de long hérissée de pièces
métalliques 6 tonnes à introduire au
coeur du tokamak s'affaire une rayure
chaque pièce fabriquée sur mesure
représente des années de recherche
[Musique]
oui je n'étais plus moi là
les neuf voix
toujours la guinée en tout chaud
me dis qu'on est robert manu aussi
faudrait tourner l'arrière dans quel
sens qu'est ce qui est non
j'aime bien ce truc parce qu'il faut
faire une bien ça touche tab ou je te le
dis etienne
à première vue on est trop bas au niveau
pour engager les rotules
[Musique]
une pièce d'un puits qui foré usine est
un petit peu mais ça nous fait perdre
deux heures
ça fait partie des aléas de montage
quand on monte des systèmes aussi
complexe que celui là avec les éléments
doivent se mettre exactement au
millimètre et quand on a un problème et
bien il faut aller à l'atelier réussie
n'est la pièce et puis l'installer vous
certes je reviens une heure plus tard
avec la pièce retouchée
oui juste un petit effort et avancer
voilà
il rentre tout seul tu re a dû remonter
un peu non enfin micro
[Musique]
même entre les expériences le vide
extrême la température et le rayonnement
résiduelles font qu'il est impossible de
pénétrer dans un tokamak la maintenance
devra donc être assuré par des robots ou
de la télé manipulation le robot aya est
capable de glisser ses dix mètres de
titane et inox au travers d'une chatière
de 25 cm en quelques heures
ils permettent à l'équipe de vérifier le
bon état des parois ou de l'appareillage
scientifique ouvrir ça veut dire que
vous repasser à la pression terrible
combat produit la chambre avec l'air
ambiant alors que là c'est la mise en
oeuvre ces
mais on ouvre un obturateur et on envoie
le robot inspectés on évite la rai
l'ouverture puis le reconditionnement de
la machine trois semaines de gagner
[Musique]
dans ces grands centres de recherche des
centaines d'expérience sont demandés par
les scientifiques pour avoir accès à la
machine il faut parfois patienter des
morts aujourd'hui simulation d'un
scénario de montée en température pour
iter
pour mettre la machine en marche on ne
se contente pas d'être fils sur un
bouton premier service et le soir on
verrait sécurité pour permettre aux
jeunes le retrait d'un lot à chaque
disjoncteur enclenché du verrines clés
qui permettent de mettre en marche le
suivant
avec des tensions de soixante trois
mille volts il n'est pas question de
courir le moindre risque et non on ne
peut pas y aller il ya un problème avec
une les portes lourde qui refuse de se
fermer les conditions de sécurité ne
sont pas remplies donc la machine ne
peut pas démarrer
pour ne pas perdre de temps philippe et
thierry un ingénieur décide de continuer
à préparer le tokamak tout en cherchant
la solution au problème de la morte
le plasma est un élément qui va émettre
des rayonnements ionisants et des
neutrons et il est absolument interdit
par mesure de sécurité à toute personne
de rester dans le hall expérimental il
prendrait un sérieux coup de soleil ou
même pour épandre des deux portraits le
rayonnement
on rigole pas avec la sécurité ici
première des opérations s'est assurée la
le bon fonctionnement de l'appartement
les tokamaks sont des machines qui sont
extrêmement complexe avec beaucoup de
sous systèmes à mettre en oeuvre
exactement au même moment tous et sous
systèmes sont sollicités à 100 % de
leurs capacités aux limites de leurs
capacités tout en assurant leur sécurité
c'est des éléments qui coûte cher vous
pouvez imaginer comme une formule 1 dans
une formule 1 on voit rouler extrêmement
vite en sollicitant maximum tous les
composants mais on assure en même temps
la sécurité du pilote oak la bac c'est
un petit peu la même chose non beaucoup
plus complète donc il n'est pas étonnant
de voir de temps en temps des petits
défauts qui apparaissent et le rôle des
gens qui sont ici c'est le réparer
rapidement cédé que pour pouvoir
poursuivre les expériences trestman
c'est évidemment quelque chose qu'on
pourra pas se permettre lorsqu'on aura
un réacteur on pourra pas se permettre
d'arrêter le réacteur pour réparer un
système pourra par contre dopé la
production
les choses sont plus compliquées qu'il
n'y paraît philippe sans le contrôle de
la journée lui échapper la société qui
s'occupe de la maintenance de la porte
lourdes ne pourra pas intervenir avant
plusieurs heures
l'équipe n'a plus qu'à se retrousser les
manches et à trouver une solution pour
sauver la journée de travail
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font ils sont
déjà descendus dans les tréfonds du
laboratoire et traquent le bug dans les
kilomètres de câblage électrique un
détecteur avait enregistré que la porte
était charmé mais les systèmes de
sécurité veillent au grain ils ont
interdit à la machine de démarrer la
porte est remise dans la position de
départ et tout rentre dans l'ordre
la porte principale quant à elle se
ferme sans problème les neutrons et
miller du fonctionnement de la machine
seront contenues par 60 centimètres de
béton
ça y est cette porte le world q2 q q 5 3
petite cause grands effets mais le
travail reprend on peut enfin commencer
les expériences
un gramme à peine de combustible de
fusion est injecté dans la chambre
d'expérience
la bobine centrale est mis sous tension
el chouf le gaspard résistance jusqu'à
20 millions de degrés deux fois la
température du coeur du soleil
aucun matériau ne pourrait supporter
cette chaleur les scientifiques ont donc
eu l'idée de confiner le plasma dans une
enveloppe immatériel un champ magnétique
intense
cent mille fois plus puissant que celui
de la terre
les particules du plasma suivent les
lignes du champ magnétique qui forment
teinte or elles ne peuvent s'écarter de
leur trajectoire
le placement est sous vide protéger de
la moindre parcelle de matières
parasites qui suffirait à le refroidir
et à l'étouffée voilà il ya des données
ya tout après un début plutôt laborieux
l'équipe met les bouchées doubles pour
rattraper le retard et finir le
programme de la journée
20 millions de degrés ne suffisent pas
pour atteindre la fusion il faut
recourir à des modes de chauffage
supplémentaire des antennes à
micro-ondes chauffe encore davantage les
quelques milligrammes de plasma c'est là
qu'intervient l'antenne qui vient d'être
installé
enfin sur iter le troisième mode de
chauffage consistera à injecter dans le
plasma des atome de deutérium à l'ultra
haute vitesse à 35 millions de
kilomètres heure l'énergie de la
collision ajoute les millions de degrés
qui manquait
pour assurer la sécurité de la machine
des sondés une caméra infrarouge
permettent de contrôler que rien ne
s'échauffe au delà du raisonnable
[Musique]
chef des charges expérimentale ne
consomme que quelques milligrammes de
gaz mais pour alimenter une réaction
continue il faut fournir du combustible
à la machine de façon régulière on fait
fusionner des atome de deutérium 1 qui
forme un atome d'hélium donc notre
combustible disparaît or à mesure qu'on
fait nos réactions de fusion donc ils
vont tout simplement fournir du
combustible à notre décharge plasma une
technique c'est d'injecter des petits
glaçons de deutérium dans le plasma
c'est glaçant vont pénétrer dans le
plasma et au fur et à mesure de leur
trajet dans le plasma vont fondre en
déposant de la matière jusqu'au coeur du
plasma alors un glaçon ici on envoie des
glaçons à une vitesse de 500 mètres par
seconde
c'est une fois et demie la vitesse du
son
[Musique]
une fois amorcée la réaction fournira la
plus grande partie du chauffage du
plasma grâce à cela iter pourra produire
dix fois plus d'énergie qu'il n'en
consommera
après 10 ans d'expérience sur iter
viendra le temps de démo le premier
réacteur enfin capable de produire de
l'électricité en continu le prototype
industriel des centres à la fusion de
demain la chaleur émise par son réacteur
entraînera des turbines à vapeur qui
produiront de l'électricité
[Musique]
avec les perspectives d'iter les progrès
sur la fusion par confinement magnétique
s'accélère d'année en année mais
d'autres équipes espèrent être les
premières à obtenir cette énergie sans
limite
elle propose une voie de recherche
totalement différente
la fusion inertielle
[Musique]
l'arme nucléaire et la production
d'énergie partagent le même domaine de
recherche
la fusion interdit depuis 1996 les
essais nucléaires sont remplacés par la
simulation informatique
les calculs ont besoin d'être vérifiées
par des expériences dont certaines
intéresse la production d'énergie par
fusion
le laser mégajoule près de bordeaux est
un laboratoire militaire mais le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
laissera la recherche civile du temps
disponible pour ses expériences ici en
étudient la fusion par confinement
inertiel
des rayons laser ultra puissant vos
coups près c'est le mélange de deutérium
tritium contenu dans une petite capsule
jusqu'à ce que leurs atomes fusionnent
françois jequier supervise l'assemblage
des installations scientifiques
vous êtes ici dans la salle d'expérience
de laser mégajoule dans le chrétien au
centre de laquelle se trouve une chambre
qui fait 10 mètres de diamètre et sur
laquelle vont converger 240 faisceaux
laser sur est aussi de taille
millimétrique
les expériences qu'on va réaliser dans
cette chambre permettront d'atteindre la
combustion thermonucléaire sera la
première étape pour réaliser ce qu'on
appelle l'énergie par fusion inertielle
c'est à dire conduire de l'électricité à
partir d'une source inépuisable qui est
l'omert donc on va tirer le carburant
pour faire cette fusion par confinement
inertiel le laser mégajoule est abrité
dans un bâtiment qui mesure 300 mètres
par 102 fois la taille du stade de
france
tous les équipements repose sur un
plancher indépendant des murs pour être
parfaitement stable
[Musique]
un ordinateur synchronise les dix mille
éléments optiques des chaînes laser
[Musique]
certains d'entre eux ne peuvent être
obtenu qu'à partir de cristal
synthétique que les ingénieurs doivent
faire pousser en laboratoire en deux
mois ils atteignent 60 cm de côté ils
seront taillées et deviendront des
optiques pour le mégajoule
au centre de ce bâtiment immense trône
la sphère d'acier
puisant change soudain d'échelle lorsque
les 240 laser frapperont leur cible elle
devrait être positionné à 50 microns
près le diamètre d'un cheveu humain
quand on réussit finalement à travailler
car pendant plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années sur un projet et qu'on
commence à voir les premiers jalons
importants franchis c'est vrai que c'est
un grand moment un grand moment de ma
vie scientifique de la construction à
l'exploitation ce que l'on appelle la
chaîne du propre et maintenu les
milliers de pièces qui composent leurs
installations vont être entièrement re
nettoyer avant de pouvoir être installée
elles sont déplacées dans un
transbordeur étanche à l'air
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au revoir
m
[Musique]
les halls laser sont en surpression pour
refouler la poussière mais le hall
d'expérience lui et dépressurisé pour
contenir toute fuite de tritium
l'ensemble des flux d'air est distribuée
et filtrées par un système qui a la
puissance des turbines d'un gros avion
de ligne
le laser mégajoule est encore en
construction mais dans le bâtiment
voisin
voici la lille ligne d'intégration laser
le prototype de l'un des lasers du
mégajoule elle ne permet pas d'atteindre
la fusion elle sert à préparer les
équipes d'ingénieurs à la maîtrise
simultanée des 240 faisceaux du
mégajoule et à effectuer des expériences
de physique des plasmas
il faut régulièrement vérifier les
amplificateurs laser
alors olivier feller favorise
pendant le dire mais ça suppose partie
sur la longueur du flash on a des
impacts à peu près à peu près dans le
même état que l'autre à peu près
et
les poussières se dépose sur les
optiques et elles sont brûlés par le
laser que je pense vu le coût des
optiques
il est évident qu'on cherche à éviter au
maximum les poussières d'où cette classe
de ces différentes classes de propreté
qui permettent d'assurer un nombre de
particules extrêmement réduits à
l'intérieur de l'amplification donc le
véhicule qui contient la cassette qui a
été enlevé de la chaîne laser est
acheminé vers les salles blanches dans
lequel on assure à sa maintenance il
faut la monter il n'y a pas de rupture
de la chaîne de propreté
on était extrêmement prendre dans
l'amplificateur ont dépassé dans un vtt
qui est très propre si et vous passez
dans une salle qui a le même niveau de
propreté que la cassette dons qu'elle
sera nettoyée et reconditionnés
[Musique]
et
un éclairage ultraviolets permet de
traquer la moindre poussière
[Musique]
outre la propreté la précision est une
vertu cardinale pour qui prétend réussir
la fusion nucléaire
le programme du jour un tir d'alignement
pour améliorer l'exactitude de la
machine mais en sécurité des cinq des
leurs pourquoi pas ressentir de plus il
faut une matinée de travail à l'équipe
pour préparer l'alignement des optiques
et la synchronisation des lasers non
mais c'est toi je t'en prie
on est en train de finaliser l'aliment
donc on va lancer de l'informatique je
pense dans le quart d'heure qui suit n'a
pas l'impulsion de départ vient d'un
laser infrarouge pas plus gros que celui
qui équipe un lecteur de cd
il a fallu plus de dix ans de recherches
pour obtenir un signal d'une qualité
suffisante
un signal parfait qui supportent d'être
amplifié 8 milliard de fois
le laser passe au travers des
amplificateurs au néodyme ce matériau
lorsqu'il est illuminé par de puissants
flash communique son énergie aux
faisceaux qui le traversent le rayon
effectué deux allers-retours collectant
davantage de puissance à chaque passage
est la création de la zone des milles 10
ans d'expérience pour préparation la
séquence de tir je répète évacuation de
la zone 10 milliards et ans pour
préparation la séquence de tir puissant
ce système d'expérience près d'un an
d'énergie communication tunisie
l'ensemble assez classe de puissance sur
le lancement de la séquence dure de
puissance
après la 4e amplification les lasers
sont tellement puissants qu'on doit
éviter de les concentrer sur moins de 40
centimètres carrés sous peine de casser
les lentilles ils convergent tous vers
la chambre d'expérience pour frapper la
cible
ok tu as vu abc des communications ici
au centième de milliardième de seconde
près les quatre laser ont touché leur
cible un point des 10 microns regardez
c'est conforme à la demande
parfaitement on ne peut pas mieux faire
lors d'un tir sur le laser mégajoule
cette précision devra être maintenu avec
une installation 60 fois plus importante
240 rayon laser vont venir frapper une
petite capsule rempli du mélange
deutérium tritium par réaction une onde
de choc portera le centre à une pression
à une température colossal les noyaux
d'atomes comprimé fusionneront avant
d'avoir eu le temps de se repousser pour
produire de l'électricité
les explosions devront être répétée
rapidement comme dans un moteur diesel
de voiture
les recherches poursuivies sur les
lasers ouvre une nouvelle voie vers la
fusion
mais en l'état le gigantisme et la
délicatesse de l'installation sont ils
vraiment compatible avec une utilisation
industrielle
faire moins fragile plus rapide moins
cher c'est ce que tente et laboratoires
sandia albuquerque aux états unis nous
sommes dans l'un des hauts lieux de la
recherche militaire américaine
[Musique]
ici l'armée américaine teste la
résistance de ces ogives nucléaires et
effectue des micros simulation
d'explosion atomique
dans la course à la fusion c'est la
troisième approche au lieu de rayons
laser ce sont des décharges électriques
qui compresse la cible ici à la z
machine on veut comprendre comment
fonctionne la fusion et ce qui est
nécessaire pour contrôler la réaction
la z machine amène la matière ou limite
d état physique que nous connaissons
très haute température et très haute
pression pour y arriver on charge des
condensateurs en énergie électrique et
on les décharges brutalement vers le
centre de la machine ce qui crée ses
états extrêmes de pression et
température il ya 20 ans on était
vraiment à la traîne dans la course à la
fusion
mais nos résultats avec l'implosion du z
pin chez les rayons x ont attiré
l'attention sur nos travaux
on est maintenant revenu dans le peloton
il est bon que les recherches sur la
fusion soit un peu concurrentiel c'est
toujours plus stimulant
intellectuellement d'avoir les angles
d'approché différents
[Musique]
muller nous avait encore moderniser la
machine on l'a presque entièrement
rénové pour doubler sa puissance on
espère se rapprocher encore de ce qui
est nécessaire pour obtenir plus
d'énergie qu'on en injecte
[Musique]
lors d'un orage l'électricité statique
s'accumulent dans les nuages
jusqu'à ce qu'elles se déchargent
brutalement en créant un éclair le tir
de la z machine fonction de la même
façon mais en vingt mille fois plus
court est mille fois plus puissant
l'électricité stockée dans une batterie
de condensateurs géants et des charges
est brutalement vers une minuscule cage
de fils d'acier fin comme le dixième
d'un cheveu la z machine concentrent
l'énergie dans le temps et l'espace pour
créer une onde de choc électrique d'une
puissance équivalant à 30 fois la
consommation instantanée de la planète
lorsque le courant traverse les
filaments il les chauffer les vapes
aurait instantanément sous la forme d'un
nuage de plasma comprimé par un puissant
champ magnétique
le plasma un plus sur la cible à la
vitesse terminale d'un million de
kilomètres heure le combustible de la bi
fusionnent en dégageant une immense
quantité d'énergie un minuscule fragment
des toiles à moissonner
je vous montre c'est ce qu'il faut pour
atteindre la fusion inertielle mon
installation représente une compression
de 30 pourquoi en diamètre comme d'un
ballon de basket à cette petite vigne en
faisant ça on augmente aussi la densité
de la matière d'origine par mille
parvient qu'à une compression de 15 à 20
pour 1 3 contrairement au laser la
machine n'est pas encore assez puissante
pour déclencher la réaction pour le
moment le plus délicat et de compresser
l'abbaye de façon parfaite
la fusion thermonucléaire
on doit compressé parfaitement
régulièrement la capsule vous voyez
quand j'essaye juste avec les mains il
ya des bosses si ça ressemble à une
crêpe
ça ne marchera pas si ça ressemble à un
ballon de rugby ou un oeuf
ça ne marchera pas non plus lors de la
compression la capsule doit rester ce
ferry qu'à 99 % et ça c'est très
compliqué
il n'est pas d'ordinateur assez rapide
pour modéliser la réaction dans son
ensemble il faut simplifier mais c'est
parfois sur ceux des roms c'est
seulement en récoltant des données que
l'on peut comparer ce qui se passe dans
la z machine avec nos simulations et
voir si elles sont exactes le couvercle
du chaudron infernale est soigneusement
refermé
mais les scientifiques ont besoin de
voir comment se comporte la cible au
moment critique dans le hangar voisin
ils ont construit un appareils
radiographiques géant baptisé zed
belette laser c'est comme si on essayait
de regarder l'intérieur du soleil à
l'oeil nu sans être aveuglé
ce laser nous permet de créer une ombre
de ce qui se passe dans la z machine
en fait on observe la réaction en ombres
chinoises sur la z machine un tir est en
préparation l'équipe du bim il est laser
se prépare à prendre une photo attention
bâtiments neufs 86e dégager les rôles
pour démarrage des opérations de tir je
répète le personnel doit évacuer les
halls immédiatement merci
la z va tirer
la lumière est si violente que si
quelqu'un se trouvait à l'intérieur ils
pourraient être rendues aveugles ou être
brûlés ou blessées si jamais il était
sur le trajet du faisceau donc pour la
sécurité du personnel ont fait sortir
tout le monde hors de portée du laser du
côté de la z machine
le compte à rebours avant ceux-ci
mi-homme mi-machine ne résisterait à la
décharge électromagnétique qui va
balayer le hall une pièce métallique mal
arrimés ou un outil oublié peuvent se
transformer en projectile le choc et qui
vont à l'explosion de plusieurs bâtons
de dynamite
[Musique]
pour réussir à prendre sa photo de
l'implosion de la capsule et binette
laser doit se synchroniser parfaitement
avec la z machine fait elle je vous
reçois vous êtes prêts oui vous pouvez
déclencher le quai c'est bon pour moi
mais attention bâtiment 9,83 z en
préparation pour tyr démarrage compte à
rebours témoins une 30 50 kg volts
témoins 10 secondes c'est que 60 kg
volts charge terminée 75 kg vol que
charge maximum armement du tir des 0
l'ondé de choc est si forte qu'on la
ressent sur toute la base c'est malin on
va récupérer nous donner le tir est un
succès
cette photo est banal à nos yeux mais
pour les scientifiques c'est une moisson
de renseignements qui valident leurs
prévisions
on a réussi à prendre une image de la
capsule où elle était en train
d'imploser
ce que l'on voit avec nos simulations
numériques
jusqu'ici nos prévisions se sont
révélées exactes
ce qui nous donne confiance dans nos
outils de calcul un de nos projets et de
ne pas utiliser le laser seulement pour
prendre les photos mais aussi pour
préchauffer la cible avant que la z
machine ne la comprend on espère que je
serai une piste intéressante pour
parvenir plus facilement la fusion comme
le laser mégajoule la z machine ne peut
effectuer qu'un tir par jour pour faire
fonctionner une centrale électrique il
faudrait au moins un tir par seconde
michael maze harakis et son équipe ont
ramené de russie un appareil qu'ils ont
perfectionné un engin simple fiable et
infatigable qui délivrent des impulsions
électriques tout absolument identique
le pacemaker d'une centrale électrique à
fusion ça c'est le prototype de ce qu'on
appelle le ltd comment ramener de tomsk
en sibérie
c'est l'élément de base pour la
construction de notre future centrale
électrique à fusion inertielle ces
modules à vous pouvez donc produire
autant d'énergie que vous le souhaitez
vous pouvez créer une centrale de
n'importe quelle taille simplement en
ajoutant des modules et ce projet qu'il
faudra cinq mille de ces engins pour
construire la première centrale
électrique 5000 dans l'univers de la
fusion tout semble démesuré mais des
économies d'échelle sur les composants
des centrales aiderait à les rendre
compétitives
michael maze harakis attend avec
impatience la livraison de la dernière
génération de cmt des russes à mener en
direct de sibérie
la collaboration entre les scientifiques
russes et américains remonte en fait au
début des années 60 en plein milieu de
la guerre froide les soviétiques comme
les américains étaient à deux doigts
d'utiliser la bombe atomique
des physiciens russes parmi lesquelles
le futur dissident andreï sakharov
venait de mettre au point le tokamak
absolument inutilisable militairement
les soviétiques furent donc impressionné
le monde par leur avance technologique
mais surtout posé les bases d'une
coopération scientifique mondiale dans
le domaine de la fusion qui aurait pu
croire il y a trente ans pouvait rien
fait ici siens américains et des
grutiers russe a déchargé un avion on
pourrait se demander pourquoi on
s'acharne à construire c'est énorme
centrale
alors qu'on se tourne vers une
production locale d'énergies
renouvelables elles ont leur place parmi
les nouvelles solutions énergétiques
pour alimenter les villes et les centres
industriels les premières générations
n'offriront qu'un faible rendement par
rapport aux possibilités immenses
offertes par la fusion mais elle
s'amélioreront au fil du temps
déjà des scientifiques envisagent une
fusion sans aucun composant radioactif
la fusion n'est pas un objectif à court
terme il faudra encore attendre quelques
décennies dans les pays développés est
encore un peu plus dans les autres ça
marchait pas là en fait moi je suis très
confiant va marcher
la question est en fait une échelle de
temps c'est donc combien de temps ça va
marcher
j'ai travaillé sur la fusion depuis les
années 80 presque vingt cinq ans a
essayé de recréer une étoile dans mon
lac
c'est vraiment une passion je pense
qu'on s'approche du résultat avec la
zenn machine les scientifiques des
différentes voies de la fusion en
particulier donc on pourrait qu'on peut
citer les trois voies qui sont la fusion
par confinement inertiel donc à partir
des lasers la fusion par confinement
magnétique et les et pitch donc ces
trois voies sont ressemblent dans une
conférence où les gens échangent
généralement des formations donc on peut
parler plus d'émulation que de réelle
concurrence au sein des équipes
la faisabilité scientifique devrait être
bientôt établi paritaire le laser
mégajoule ou la z machine
les premiers prototypes industriels
suivront rapidement et enfin les plus
jeunes d'entre nous devraient connaître
d'électricité de fusion peut-être vers
2070 d'ici là les économies d'énergie
ont encore de beaux jours devant elle
[Musique]
il
je
[Musique]